Well, let's get started.
Taking a look down here at the bottom, one of the first things we print
out is funone x is Hong Kong.
The only Hong Kong we ever see in the program
is the first argument to funone
so that means that this must be x.
Funone y is outside y,
which means that we can't have overwritten it here.
If we put y in this box,
we would mistakenly get out 1997,
and we don't see that.
So it can't be x because we just used x; it can't be y,
so let's try z.
If we pass in 1997 as z, then y will still refer to this old value of outside y,
we'll get the printout that we expect.
Then we call funtwo, and down here
if we take a look at the printout, x remains unchanged.
X is still outside x, but y is funone y.
The place we see that is right here, it's the parameter being passed in.
So in order from funone y to the flow here,
we have to fill in this box with y.
Note that the way scoping works,
funone and funtwo are independent,
so even though funone has overwritten x,
funtwo still sees the old outside value.
Well, let's test this answer and see if it's right.
I will just add a little more information,
and we get exactly the output we were expecting.
Some actual information that Hong Kong is a
special administrative region in China,
was controlled by the UK until 1997,
and then down here,
just the output we had hoped to get for this puzzle.